por aquí tenemos una función llamada hdn
y vamos a decir que de manera explícita
define los términos de una sucesión así
que hagamos una pequeña y rápida tabla
por aquí para ver qué me dice esta
función por aquí voy a tener a n y por
aquí voy a tener a h de n ahora
supongamos que n toma el valor de 1
tiene toma el valor de 1 bueno pues aquí
me quedaría menos 31 menos 7 que
multiplica a 1 - 1
ahora date cuenta que uno menos uno me
va a dar cero y por siete me va a dar
cero así que esta parte de aquí se
cancelaría y me quedaría simple y
sencillamente -31 qué pasa si n vale 2
bueno si n baleados me quedaría menos 31
menos 7 que multiplica a 2 menos
102 - 1 es muy simple esto es 1 por lo
tanto me quedarían menos 7 por 1 lo cual
es menos 7 y entonces menos 31 habrá que
quitarle menos 7 y eso
va a dar menos 38 y 100 a vale 3 bueno
pues me quedaría menos 31 menos 7 por 3
menos uno lo cual es 27 por 2 ok ahora
date cuenta que en este caso me voy a
tomar a menos 31 y le voy a quitar dos
veces 7 es decir me va a quedar menos 31
menos 14 lo cual es menos 45 muy bien
pero veamos que está pasando aquí
empezamos en menos 31 y después cada
paso que nosotros demos vamos a estar
quitando 7 otro paso más y por lo tanto
vamos a quitar 7 si te das cuenta eso es
lo que está pasando en esta sucesión es
decir restar 7 una vez menos que la vez
que nos dice el término por ejemplo aquí
en el tercer término hemos restado 2
veces 7 aquí en este segundo término
hemos restado sólo 17 y bueno es justo
lo que está pasando
así que hasta aquí todo está padre pero
ahora lo que quiero es que pausa es el
vídeo y ver si puedes definir la misma
sucesión es decir hasta aquí tenemos la
sucesión menos 31 después están menos 38
después está menos 45 después el que
sigue sería menos 7 sería menos 52 y así
sigue y sigue sigue con esta misma
sucesión
lo que quiero es ahora que encuentres la
función recursiva de esta sucesión ya
tenemos aquí de una manera explícita la
sucesión pero ahora lo que quiero buscar
es la forma recursiva de expresarla ok
entonces manos a la obra lo primero que
quiero que veas es que a esta función la
voy a llamar head
cdn va a ser mi función recursiva y
bueno esta función es muy sencilla en
primer lugar podemos decir lo siguiente
si n vale 1 que va a pasar bueno déjame
escribirlo si n es igual a 1 nuestro
primer término de esta sucesión recuerda
que es menos 31 así que si en a vale 1
nuestro primer término de esta
asociación es menos 31 ahora qué pasa si
n es un número más grande que 1 y bueno
como estamos definiendo una sucesión
también n debe de ser un número natural
número natural es decir un entero
positivo y bueno si en el más grande que
uno hay es un número natural como
obtenemos el que sigue bueno pues muy
fácil agarramos el término anterior es
decir que de n
1 ya esto le quitamos 7 date cuenta que
así llegamos al que sigue nos tomamos el
término anterior y le quitamos 7 así que
si agarramos cualquier término al azar
bueno pues nos fijamos en el anterior ya
éste le restamos 7 y obtenemos el
siguiente término y esta función está
muy fácil y muy sencilla darte cuenta de
lo siguiente si tú tienes cualquier
término y no sabes cuál es el anterior
bueno tú puedes seguir regresando y
regresando y regresando todos los
términos hasta llegar al caso base al
inicio en donde n vale 1 y así esta
función me va a definir esta sucesión
perfecto es hora de hacer otro ejercicio
y para eso voy a bajar mi pantalla pero
ahora va a ser el caso
voy a empezar con una función escrita de
manera recursiva y yo lo que voy a
querer es mi función que describa esta
sucesión pero de una manera explícita
así que veamos que nos dice esta función
lo que nos dice es que nos da la
siguiente sucesión en el primer término
tenemos un 9.6 si n vale 1
empezamos con 9.6 ese es nuestro caso
base y después cada término siguiente es
el anterior menos 0.1 así que el segundo
término va a ser el anterior menos 0.1
me va a quedar 9.6 menos 0.1 lo cual es
9.5 el que sigue va a ser el anterior
este menos 0.1 que va a ser 9.4 y
después va a ser 9.3 y así me voy a
mantener siguiendo y siguiendo y
siguiendo siguiendo esta sucesión ahora
también lo podemos hacer en forma de
tabla si yo me tomo por aquí una tabla
déjenme hacer por acá una pequeña tabla
y por aquí voy a poner la otra parte de
la tabla
en este dado voy a tener a n y en este
otro a hdn y bueno si en avales 1
entonces vamos a tomarnos el principio
9.6 justo esto es lo que me dice la
función si n vale 1 entonces mi valor en
esa sucesión es 9.6 ahora qué pasa si n
vale 2 siena vale 2
entonces voy a tener hd2 menos 1 es
decir h de uno ya esto habrá que
quitarle 0.1 estás de acuerdo en este
caso me va a quedar bueno tengo que
fijarme en el término anterior que es
9.6 ya esto quitarle 0.1 por lo que me
va a quedar 9.5 y quien es ht3 bueno si
n vale 3 entonces hd 3 es lo mismo que h
de 3 - 1 es decir hd2 menos 0.1 dicho de
otra manera esto va a ser exactamente
igual que hay que fijarnos en hd 2 pero
hd 2 lo tenemos aquí es 9.5 y después
quitarle 1
por lo que nos va a quedar 9.4 y así me
puedo seguir y seguir y seguir ahora la
pregunta es y lo que quiero que piense
es cómo podemos escribir esta misma
sucesión o esta misma función pero de
una forma explícita ya lo tenemos aquí
de una forma recursiva ahora lo que
quiero es encontrar la forma explícita
de esta sucesión bueno pues vamos a
hacerlo a esta función vamos a llamarle
efe
y en un principio parece sencillo
empezamos en 9.6 9.6 y le vamos a quitar
0.1 pero cuántas veces le vamos a quitar
0.1 vamos a quitarle una cierta cantidad
de veces primero empezamos con 9.6 y no
le quitamos 0.1 y en el segundo término
date cuenta que le quitamos una vez 0.1
en el tercer término le quitamos dos
veces 0.1 y en el cuarto término ya le
hemos quitado una dos tres veces 0.1 por
lo tanto en fdn debe ser una función que
dependa de n y entonces nos va a quedar
9.6 menos 0.1 que multiplica a el número
de términos del que estamos hablando
menos 1
es decir le vamos a quitar n 1 veces 0.1
a 9.6 para encontrar el término n y tú
puedes evaluarlo y ver que en verdad
funciona sin nivel de uno bueno pues me
va a quedar un números uno lo cual es
cero esto se elimina y solamente me
quedaría 9.6 ahí vamos muy bien si n
vale 2 me quedarían dos menos uno es uno
por lo tanto le quitaríamos solamente
una vez 0.1 a 9.6 y llegaríamos al 9.5 y
así nos podremos mantener evaluando esta
función de hecho podría ser una tabla y
evaluar esta misma función pero aquí la
clave de todo esto de lo que quiero que
te des cuenta es que empiezas en 9.6 y
le vas a quitar 0.1 una vez menos del
número de término que tú estés buscando
esta es la clave por ejemplo si tú
quieres el término 4
bueno pues habrá que restarle tres veces
0.1 a 9.6 entonces cuando en es igual a
4 hemos quitado tres veces 0.1
y date cuenta que va una vez aquí va
otra vez y aquí tenemos la tercera vez
quitamos 0.1 tres veces